what up space fam goes in here and for
anime up for and today we are going to
be talking about the class 1b students
and all of their quirks I actually made
a similar video back in the day but that
was before we actually knew all the
quirks and I had to speculate now we
have a lot more information about the
quirks so it's about time for an updated
video if you want to see more videos
like this one including other updated my
hero academia videos make sure to smash
that like button to let me know if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial hit that notification bell so
you actually know when you MHA videos
drop we have a huge playlist of my hero
academia videos available for you on
this channel already you can now find
all of our videos in audio format on
Spotify and Apple music if you look up
anime up roar audio or just check out
the links in the description you can
also find a link to our twitch in the
description where we discussed the
latest chapters of my hero academia and
other popular manga live with you guys I
hope to see you there
keep in mind there will be manga
spoilers in this video now without
further ado let's jump into everyone's
second favorite class class one be side
note I know there will be that one guy
in the comments was like well actually
class 1b is my favorite and Natal
Monomoy is the true protagonist of my
hero academia anyways let's start with
the class welder and mobile carrier yo
set su Alice a according to the mangaka
Co hey ho Takashi his bandana makes him
look super cool and he gets bonus points
for saving our beautiful Momo from the
chainsaw no move
very cool Alice a very cool according to
the ultra analysis book he got 2 out of
6 in power a foreign speed a 5 and
technique a foreign intelligence and a 4
in ability to stop you in your tracks
his quirk is called weld and it allows
him to fuse objects together at the
atomic level if he is touching both
things this lets him attach trackers to
Frankenstein inspired creatures called
Nobu
he later uses steel logs that give him
more flexibility his attack weld craft
lets him quickly trap opponents by
binding them with metallic logs to a
wall he used this attack on Bakugan but
the key though the sugar hero was there
to free him this attack would be much
more effective if Alice says logs were
unbreakable and he had an unbreakable
or floor to use but as things stand his
abilities aren't super effective in
battle I'm sure he would make a great
construction worker though next let's
turn to Sin Cara aka spiral the usually
calm dude of class 1b we're told he's a
good-looking dude and his statistics are
pretty impressive
he got fours in power speed technique
and intelligence and a 5 in harsh way of
thinking seems like he can be a bit of a
buzz killington his quirk is called
gyrate and it lets him spend parts of
his body as if they were drills this
increases his offensive abilities enough
that or judo the tail Jedi complains
that he can't even guard against his
swings sen uses a support item on his
fingers that's so hard that it will
drill through most people's defenses or
jury also mentions that his own attacks
would just bounce off chimera because of
the spinning either the straight-laced
sonic of class 1a catches him off guard
but chi bada claims that he hasn't even
gotten a chance to show his full power
which is impressive because he was
already easily outclassing or judo his
teacher even says that kybella was the
real MVP of the battle because his drill
quirk was wearing down his opponents
like either even when it didn't seem
like it I definitely expect big things
from this guy in the future spiral
energy for the wind toll guru kamakiri
is next the guy with an insect looking
face and hella cool hair he's pretty
much the cytha of class 1 beat he scored
a 4 out of 6 in power foreign speed 3 in
technique 3 in intelligence and 5 in
sharpness his quirk razor sharp allows
him to produce blades from all over his
body
like from his forearms he would make for
an excellent assassin if he didn't stand
out so much the blades are sharp and
strong enough to cut through metal pipes
and they can even withstand explosions a
very cool power even if it couldn't do
much against the Baku goats she high
crude oil is also known as the scheming
hero vantablack he's the fumika a of
class 1b you can also get pretty dark
and dramatic when he talks he scored a 2
out of 6 in power a foreign speed a 5
and technique a 2 in intelligence and a
4 in appearing out of nowhere
his quirk is called black and it allows
him to merge into anything that is dark
he can move dark things he's merged into
if they can normally move for instance
at one point he merged with
kagaz quark dark shadow and had an
attack fumika gave he can travel
insanely fast when merged with the
darkness and shadows in an area he was
able to grab a yama and carry him off
before he or Momo could react however as
was fool me cog a lightness as natural
weakness and can significantly limit his
quirks effectiveness Asuka Kendall aka
battle fist is a pretty and cheerful
girl with man hands
she is the big sister of class 1b and
the class representative kendo is the
one who karate chops natal Monomoy when
he gets out of hand she scored a 5 out
of 6 in power a 3 and speed a 3 and
technique a 5 in intelligence and a 5 in
big sis her quirk is called the big fist
and as the name suggests it lets her
make her fists big her gigantic hands
increased the power of her attacks and
let her easily grab people it's amazing
that she can not only lift her giant
hands but she can even lift and carry
other people with them without a problem
she can use her hands - Krieg gusts of
wind powerful enough to clear an area of
gas during her joint training battle
kendall comes up with her team strategy
and she goes on to fight momo one-on-one
mobile creates a shield out of tungsten
a metal that is much harder than steel
and more resistant to fracturing than
diamond yet the shield is no match for
Kendall's hands and kendall manages to
send momo flying back her special move
double jumbo fist increases the speed
and strength of her strikes even more
she waits for the moment of impact to
grow her fists
Kendal's team goes on to beat momo steam
in large part because of her
strategizing and strength fun bonus fact
according to the popularity polls kendo
is the most popular soon in class 1 v
let me know who your favorite class 1b
student is in the comment and use your
possibly giant hands to smash that like
button you Ecola die aka rule is a quiet
girl and often comes off as emotionless
she can seem cold but she does care
about her classmates and will help them
when the chips are down you he scored a
2 out of 6 in power a 3 and speed a 5
and technique a 3 and intelligence and a
perfect 6 and coolness her quirk is
called size and unless her changed the
size of nonliving things that she
touches she can for instance shrink
something throw it out an opponent and
then
turn it to its normal size with required
so that delivers maximum damage to the
opponent alternatively she can take
something small and increase its size
kinoko Kimani AKA mage is the mushroom
girl of class 1b her eyes used to be
completely covered by her hair and she
wore a gloomy expression but we saw her
eye and her more upbeat side during the
joint training battle you can also count
on her to provide shroom errific
mushroom based puns she scored a 1 out
of 6 in power a 1 in speed a 5 and
technique a 3 in intelligence and a 4 in
idol the last category is a reference to
her desire to become a famous idol not
surprisingly Kinoko squirt is called
mushroom her court lets her shoot spores
from her body that instantaneously grow
into fields of mushrooms the mushrooms
spread and grow faster in humid
conditions which is why she uses a
squirt gun that raises the humidity of
her surroundings the mushrooms can
spread across an insanely large area and
they even grow on people's bodies as
seen during the joint training battle
when fumika he catches her she uses
split Gill shrooms to attack his lungs
nato comments that Kinoko is truly an
opponent to fear because of her quirk
fumika is rendered pretty much powerless
Kinoko apologizes and lets home acog a
know that he can get some medicine from
recovery girl it might not surprise you
that keno close favorite things or
mushrooms eBrush use a key a key a vine
has vines for hair Ibarra is portrayed
as a super religious person who thinks
she's superior to those around her she
uses religious names for her attacks
like crucifixion and faiths shield while
referring to others as sinners she
scored a 3 out of 6 in power a foreign
speed a 5 in technique a 2 in
intelligence and a 5 in holiness her
quirk is called vines she can manipulate
her hair vines as she pleases the vines
can grow extremely long and even travel
through the ground she uses them for
attack defense and order to grab people
she can detach the vines at will and
they will regrow if her hair gets enough
sunlight and water during the joint
training battle she covers the whole
area of the battlefield with her vines
in order to drag out combinati
but then she encases him inside and/or
bovines
another interesting thing about her is
that in accordance with her religious
theme her
hero costume is just the plain white
robe she's already Opie and I guess
she'd be even more formidable if she got
some more helpful customized equipment
judo Tichina akj vu d'en he is clearly
inspired by the beast from x-men who
also wears glasses is covered with fur
and has teeth protruding from his lower
lip
I mean judo - squirt is even called B's
and homage doesn't get any more obvious
than this
he speaks intelligently and shows
respect in his normal form but gets more
wild when he transforms he scored a 5
out of 6 in power a foreign speed a 3 in
technique III and intelligence and a 5
in way with words as mentioned his quirk
is called beast it allows him to enter
beast mode which gives him a massive
boost in strength hearing vision and
sense of smell the transformation also
makes him wildly enthusiastic in this
mode he towers over most opponents he's
fast and strong enough to sneak up on
kitty Shima and sent him flying he can
also change back into human mode in
midair to dodge an attack and then
quickly transform back to beast mode he
uses this to grab both Kirishima and
koji at the same time his speed power
and senses definitely make him one of
the most dangerous students in class 1b
and his favorite things are taking naps
I can definitely relate to that
Nealon Gehrke shoda AKA mind is a chubby
humble dude who looks like he loves
Dragon Ball Z this costume consists of
what looks like a scatter over his left
eye and a dragon radar on the back of
his hand his statistics are impressive
despite shota's humbleness he scored a 5
out of 6 in power a 3 in speed a foreign
technique a foreign intelligence and a 5
in class one B's conscience his work is
called twin impact we are told that
after striking an object shuriken
activate a second strike remotely that
second hit will have a ton more oomph to
it in other words anything struck once
will receive a second stronger blow
after or chuckle used her ability to
make a number of objects float should I
use twin impact to send them flying at
them again with even greater force he
uses the ability to run faster jump
higher and strengthen his attacks when
not training or battling show the likes
to watch boxing matches pony to Natori
is a
and naive foreign student who is still
learning Japanese NATO takes advantage
of this and teaches her insults to use
against class 1-a she is action English
speaker and uses English when she gets
angry she scored a three out of six in
power he foreign speed a five in
technique a three in intelligence and a
five in broken English her quirk is
called horn cannon and it lets her shoot
her horns as if they were cannonballs
new horns grow back soon and she can
shoot those two she can control up to
four horns at a time the horns can
create enough force to send or j'adore
into jail during the joint training
battle one horns strong enough to lift a
person and she uses her horns to place
herself and three other people out of
Shoji's reach high in the sky Shoji
cannot touch her and the match ends up
in a draw thanks to her pony's favorite
thing is anime so I'm sure we can all
relate to her colse subbu dhaba is a
plain dude who is fine with settling for
less in contrast to characters like baka
go and midoriya who are driven to aim
for the top he scored a two out of six
in power a three and speed a five and
technique a foreign intelligence and a
five and got your back his quirk is
called solid air and it allows him to
solidify the air he breathes out I never
saw this kind of superpower before but
it's very interesting kossei can make
platforms walls and even soundproof
confinement cells of solidified air
since he has to breathe the air out his
quirk is limited by his lung capacity he
was captured during the joint training
battle but all he could think about was
the fact that suyus tongue had been all
over his body
Tatsu Tatsu Tatsu Tatsu aka Real Steel
he is a Silver Surfer clone of Kirishima
and even his name points to his
repetitiveness Petro Tetsu can be loud
arrogant and has a very straightforward
fighting style
he's also brave and threw himself in
front of a bullet for big sis Kendall he
scored a 5 out of 6 in power a 2 in
speed a 2 in technique a 3 in
intelligence and a 5 and manliness he
actually didn't score as high as Konishi
mind this last category since red riot
got a perfect 6 out of 6 and manliness
Tetsu Tetsu's quirk is called steel and
it allows him to turn his skin into
steel giving him a strong defense and
offense Tatsu Tatsu Square seems to be
fueled by his iron intake if he doesn't
have enough iron in his
his steel skin will lose its durability
when using his quirk he can withstand
giant robots falling on him and bullets
being shot at him his steel skin gives
him immunity to freezing and resistance
to heat but it will eventually melt if
the heat gets high enough Tatsu Tatsu
breaks through Totoro keys ice with no
problem
he gets Todoroki he recommended student
and one of class one is best to go on
the defensive he survives what appears
to be Totoro keys best efforts to
overwhelm him with his flames
she even shouts back no running away
when ena runs off with a passed-out
Todoroki he pushes a giant structure
down on either and takes him out of
commission before passing out himself it
was an extremely impressive and manly
spectacle when he's not training to
death touch of touch who likes eating
spinach and playing fighting games
setsuna token gay aka lizardy is
described as confident talkative and
provocative many class 1b students look
to her for leadership her statistics are
amazing she scored a three out of six in
power and fives in speed technique
intelligence and all over the place
her quirk is called lizard tail splitter
and it is similar to buggy the clown's
powers from one piece she can split her
body into 50 different pieces and
control them the pieces can even fly and
regenerate however regeneration is very
exhausting and she would prefer to
recall all of her body parts if possible
it is also suggested that she needs to
return parts of her body every so often
to reset their time limit she can use
her quirk to spy on people track down
people distract people or to attack them
obviously the attacks aren't super
powerful but there's a pretty good
trade-off since she's also practically
invincible BOTS can go comments that the
pieces that attacked him were too small
to target and even if they did manage to
get hit setsuna could regenerate a fun
fact about the talented setsuna is that
she likes dinosaurs manga Fuki dashi aka
comic man is the WTF character within
the anime I don't even know how he makes
sense within a world as crazy as my hero
academia but I ain't complaining he's
clearly a source of metahuman Akashi who
is himself a kind of comic-book hero
manga scored an impressive 5 out of 6 in
power a foreign speed a three and
technique a three and intelligence and a
1 in vocabulary
that last score might be some
self-deprecating humor from horikoshi
where he's playing off the stereotype
that comics are inferior to high
literature which tends to pay a lot of
attention to language and vocabulary
mangas quirk is called comic and it lets
him materialize onomatopoeias into
reality so pretty much he can make sound
effects come true
sounds like BAM can actually create
destruction and words that suggests
humidity can actually make the
surrounding area humid if he over uses
the quirk he'll get a sore throat it may
not surprise you to learn that manga
likes drawing in his free time and
making children smile just like a
real-life mangaka Jews Ohana nuki AKA
mud man looks like the attack Titan of
class 1b he got into UA on
recommendations like Todoroki and Momo
he hates losing but he is willing to
make a strategic retreat when conditions
are not favorable his statistics are
very impressive he scored a three out of
six in power and then fives and speed
technique intelligence and flexible
thinking this quirk is called softening
and it lets him soften any nonliving
thing he touches he can also release the
effect and return things back to normal
like an earthbender he can turn solid
earth into quicksand in order to
immobilize his opponents he is able to
swim through material he softens giving
him a huge advantage over his
immobilized opponents he's the one that
finally stops to the rookie in the joint
training battle in addition to being
super smart strong and talented
Juuso can also speak English and has
conversations with Pony in English
quad judo bundle aka plum o has a very
unique look he's another student like
manga who is hard to take too seriously
he is like a walking talking tube of
glue he's described as a gentle giant
similar to Koji from class 1a he scored
a four of six in power a three and speed
III in technique III and intelligence
and an impressive 5 in adhesive strength
this guy sure would have been useful in
elementary school
his quirk is called semi Dean which is
actually a kind of glue that is popular
in Japan kojirou squirt lets him squirt
copious amounts of fast drying glue from
the many holes in his head he can
apparently control how quickly the glue
dries it's a good quirk for trapping
people and for gluing things together
during the joint training battle he made
the entire area sticky with his
glue but baku goal was not about to let
that stop him from winning cordial likes
to put together plastic models and the
best part is that he never has to pay
for glue nato Manama AKA phantom thief
is the guy you love to hate he is
jealous of class 1a spa polarity and his
life mission seems to be to beat class
1a because of his quirk nato thinks that
he can never be the main character in
the story only a side character which is
sad because it's totally true he is a
side character but at least he's an
entertaining one and in his defense he
is always supportive of his fellow
classmates he scored a 1 out of 6 in
power a 1 in speed a 5 and technique a 5
in intelligence and a perfect 6 in
provocation
NATO's quirk is called copy and it
allows him to copy a person's quirk
after he touches them he is able to hold
for quirks at a time but he can't use
them simultaneously
he needs to switch back and forth
between them the limit of each quark
runs out 10 minutes after he touched the
original user when it comes to quirks
that requires stored power like one for
all he cannot effectively copy them and
he cannot copy quirks that include extra
body parts like og dos tail
he is also limited by the strength of
his own body NATO squirt is awesome
because he can pick the best quirks
available and use his intelligence to
put them to good use in battle he has no
problem using quirks like Konishi most
hardened or Yui size effectively in
battle but of course she has revealed
that Monomoy is based on a real person
and that makes sense because I think we
have all had a Monomoy in our life at
one point or another they call Yanagi
aka emily is the spooky girl of class 1b
who walks around like a zombie she is
usually quiet and emotionless she scored
a 2 out of 6 in power a 3 and speed a 5
in technique a 3 in intelligence and a 5
and fixation of hands her quirk is
called poltergeist and it allows her to
manipulate nearby objects she can't move
more than the total weight of a single
person at a time her power can work
especially well in conjunction with yui
size quirk while vehicle launch is a
number of small objects at the enemy Yui
can make them much larger and heavier
right before they hit the enemy when she
isn't being spooky on the battlefield
Vaiko enjoys internet surfing here you
Dean aka
dragon shroud he is
foreigner like pony except he appears to
be from China he scored a three out of
six in power a three and speed a foreign
technique a five and intelligence and a
5 in chineseness his quirk is called
scales and allows him to grow tough
scales on his skin like a reptile in a
sense his powers similar to Kitty chimas
hardening and it increases his defensive
and offensive abilities it even can also
fire his scales at opponents with
significant strength and speed so scale
bullets plus scale armor pretty much
sums up his quark bonus points go to
Dean for choosing a dragon theme for his
hero persona because dragons are very
cool and everyone knows it and that is
it for today's video
I bet this video is going to be pretty
long when it's all done since these
types of videos always take long to make
it would really mean a lot to me if you
could smash that like blend to help with
the YouTube algorithm and if you could
share this video with a friend if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial hit that notification bell so
you actually know when you MHA videos
come out for more content and updates on
the new MHA seasons you can follow us on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar a
special thank you goes out to our
patrons on patreon who help us survive
YouTube issues and who helped make
videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings ell
dress fitted ala beat Anatole cos ASCII
alpha do angel Cruz and team Sparky 65
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans Steven n grata
a lull on attend Matty Mac 239
makoto-kun the world Steelers Tyson
Corino and the school bus thank you all
so much if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon comm anime uproar and becoming a
patron today for as little as $1 if you
do so you'll get your name feature in
future videos alongside these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to her private patron only
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course dank memes so check out
patreon.com/lenguin
you can also now join the youtube
channel and support more content that
way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits
till next time see you space cowboy
[Music]
you